treat every client like it's an annual
deal not just a one-off what are the two
to seven things that you're doing most
consistently for clients and then
pricing those out as different packages
that you can help with every new client
you bring on is 30 more and then you
have a conversation with existing
clients to increase the rate that's a
new service now that's an extra 1500
bucks a month
so how to raise your rates when you
realize you are under charging your
clients and customers every new client
you bring on is 30 more and then you
have a conversation with existing
clients to
increase the rate
and you may lose some people
but if it's a good it's a good spot to
be in I mean the
there may be one or two people that you
keep on just because you love them and
and they just it feels good to work with
them and help them but they're you know
they can't afford the new rates and so
you keep those on other people uh can
easily afford it and and they have to
decide what they're going to spend it
and and other people you move on from if
there's anybody you can recommend them
to great otherwise you're
you're moving on and you start targeting
more ideal clients and I went through
this with
um
a couple times now with different
YouTube you know we started with Jeremy
who
you know now is mid five figures sorry
mid yeah five figures mid five figures
every month
and his goal is to have 12 ideal clients
who are paying him 5K a month to help
him
yeah I don't know Jeremy but I did
recently connect with Drew and yeah I
had a meeting with him because Zan the
man hooked us up uh introduced us so we
we scheduled a meeting yeah and and so
that was eye-opening that was very very
eye-opening to see to see what how Drew
has been how he has structured his
business because it made me realize that
I need to I need to
um recalibrate right yeah well the
number one thing I did when when I
helped when I invested into Drew was
start to renegotiate his current deals
it's like okay wow you're doing way too
much like this is just you're you're
you're not getting you're giving a lot
of value not getting paid so and listen
at the beginning this is helpful for
everybody at the beginning of a coaching
business
you're just figuring stuff out
you're you're happy that any client is
coming to you you're getting paid to do
what you love it's great
um I think a couple things that will
help
uh one
treat every client like it's an annual
deal not just a one-off so even Drew
turned away deals that hey can you help
me for this month like um
you can't get enough Can't Get Enough
value out of it so every now for
depending on the business maybe you can
but by default you want to think about
turning people into annual deals so you
know Terry's going to coach somebody on
how to write a book great let's turn
that into uh what does an annual deal
look like what is a book every year look
like and just default into that kind of
thinking instead of the one-offs
next is breaking down the product offer
so that when you are not just you know
I'll do everything for you for YouTube
great
that's a good starting point but then
you need to start breaking it down so
there's strategy strategy once a month
or every two weeks June and um Jeremy do
every two weeks because for strategy you
don't have enough for uh for every week
and if you're doing it every week you
become
uh more of a project manager which is
maybe what you want to do as opposed to
actually strategy not enough happens
week to week to really justify strategy
um so if you want to be project manager
and I'm going to talk to the designer
and I'm going to get this done and I'm
going to basically as you said insert
yourself into the organization if that's
what you love doing then you have a
project management fee
you have a strategy fee
you have a
split testing fee yes like optimization
fee so so Drew and Jeremy will do
strategy split testing for a certain
number of thumbnails and titles going
back and then guidance on things like
mashup videos uh so everything that you
do is now split
and people can pick packages that they
go for with all of it or they can just
do the one thing and what that helps is
prevent scope creep to then say
oh well Andrew can you also help with
this you know and how about this and and
this too when she's already doing that
can you that happens you're talking my
language Evan thank you yeah that has
most certainly happened that's exactly
where I'm at right now and that happens
to every Consulting business every
coaching business scope creep it's just
the I didn't know that was the term
thank you the scope of the project just
creeps forward right it's like oh and
Terry would you mind also doing this and
how about that it's like that's a whole
other offering that I that I given
listen it's not that you always say no
and you you know you bend a bit but at
some point now if this is every month
that I'm doing this it has to be part of
some kind of offering that we're putting
together
um so some of it can be organic and you
work towards but when you get enough I'm
not so worried about the beginning part
don't worry about having the perfect
plan together but as you get into it you
start to see the pattern so you know for
Jeremy for example he didn't want to do
thumbnails and split testing at the
beginning and and one of his clients
just badly needed it
because she didn't have anybody who
could do it so he said okay you know
what I'm gonna help her and I'm going to
do it and then he realized oh you know
what it's actually not that hard and
I've gained skills to do it
great I'm going to do this for other
clients too awesome try but you have to
charge for it Jeremy that's a new
service now that's an extra 1500 bucks a
month to do split testing on your
catalog that kind of stuff so what I
would look for you is what are the how
do you how would you break it down into
the two to seven things that you're
doing consistently for clients not
nickel and diming them about
every single minute of every phone call
is being like like a lawyer would do you
know that's not what the business you
want to be in but also clients don't
know what goes on behind the scenes they
might just assume it's just easy this
one little thing for you to do right
where it's no no this is actually taking
on a life of its own and now I'm very
deep into your project
um so what are the two to seven things
that you're doing most consistently for
clients and then pricing those out as
different packages that um that you can
help with
that makes sense and in this situation
of if you are working with a client that
you enjoy working with but maybe perhaps
they're on a tighter budget does it make
sense for a YouTube expert to lower the
base fee and just ask to participate in
the YouTube ad Revenue do a red split a
web share
um
you could if you see upside you know if
you
sometimes people will do it based off of
a minimum so you know like the first
three thousand dollars a month comes to
you
and you invest in them to help them and
guide them and if you can't help them
you know if they're only making 500
bucks a month then you get the 500 bucks
but you get the first 3 000 or whatever
number you want to put in there that's
worth it for you you get the first so
you're working towards it and then
afterwards what do you
what do you want to work on
um together does that is it your stop
and you just make 3K a month is it then
some kind of share afterwards because it
turns into more of a partnership at that
point right yeah and so you have to pick
those clients extra carefully because
you're investing a ton of time at the
start to do the work and then when they
end up succeeding hopefully like when do
they even do the work to succeed because
only so much you can do as the guy
behind the scenes they have to make
videos you know if they're not making
content and you can't wave a magic wand
then just help you blow up
um I do have one client that I'm
constantly like where are your videos
need your videos yeah it says like do
you still want to work with them you
know is it an ideal client for you or
not
um
and then working towards if I'm going to
take a piece of their Channel forever is
that is it just somebody you love
working with is it a good partner for
you
or not and as you start the build you
get a little more spoiled you can be a
little more picky you know with who you
bring on the kinds of people that you
want to work with
yeah yeah I've I've recently had some
very interesting conversations looks
like I've onboarded my first celebrity
actually so things are things are things
are going quick and I'm trying to be
smart about it and scale in an
appropriate manner so that all my
clients still receive the value that
they're used to receiving from me so
thank you very much Evan I don't want to
take up everyone's time but uh yeah
thank you and just super quick like as
you keep as you keep growing it's for
everybody too hope everybody's valuing
you know the conversation
um the kinds of clients that you want to
work with so for example Jeremy right
now on the YouTube world is only going
after pretty giant names like they're
all everybody on this Client List you
would recognize who they were and what
they're doing
um and that's what he loves doing
um Bo who I've recently invested into he
does he books he books guests for shows
so he he books he got me Matthew
McConaughey and Deepak Chopra and all
these people and then we turned that
into a service for other people so if
you have a podcast or YouTube channel
and you're looking to get some good
guests for it Beau will book the guest
for you
um which is great because that's a big
part of
writing a show is booking guests but
Beau doesn't want to work with the big
name shows Beau likes working with the
people who are on their way up not that
not the totally brand new like
I'm never going to make any money but he
he likes finding people who already have
they have a budget they've had some
success in the entrepreneur world and
they want to launch their show and they
have a budget to launch the show but
they're not people that you know of yet
and he likes
being a part of helping them grow
so it's just a totally different
clientele than what someone like Jeremy
is going after and and at the end of the
day you get the pick you know as you at
the beginning you're exploring and you
don't really know until you start
working with them so working with that
celebrity great amazing and maybe that
that's all you want to do then is work
with more celebrities or you may realize
I actually hate working with these
celebrities I'd rather work with the
level below and help them become and
that's where I get my biggest
satisfaction there's no right answer
it's more what does Andrew want to do
um and for everybody else as you start
getting into the coaching business you
get the pick because of all the things
that's the most like working with a bad
client a non-ideal fit client starts to
suck the soul out of you because it's
your actual time that you're spending
every week with them
um so those learnings of the people who
you want to start working with become
important as you build your coaching
practice thank you what do we got
uh thanks Evan for your time again
or taking our questions today and um I
just wanted some feedback I just started
my YouTube channel last month so it's
brand new
um just wanted your opinion on am I
doing well or am I not
um it's called Soul aligned vision
how often are you posting uh once a week
okay so let's work to up that
okay twice a week or as much as you can
because because part of it is just
developing the skill set of getting
getting better
okay where if you're if you're
practicing anything once a week anything
the odds of you getting really good at
it are pretty low okay so as as much as
you can
um I'd be making more videos uh I'd be
going longer like most of the years I'm
looking at like five six minutes yeah
10 minutes plus
okay we just talked about this inside
Movie Makers today like I'd be leaving
looking towards hour long videos if you
have enough con like you can actually
speak to it but at least 10 minutes on
it okay
um and then just just more just more
more videos more videos
like I would I wouldn't judge yourself
until you have 100 videos on the channel
okay
and you've got seven which is great hey
seven first seven are the hardest to do
that's amazing but you know seven videos
listen seven videos in four weeks that's
a that's a good start
um but if you really want to start
picking up traction
I'd be I'd have Ambitions to go to one
video a day that are you know 10 minutes
plus each one
okay and and don't don't worry as much
about the editing I don't know if you
are worried about the editing or what
you're doing but
um I'm not because it was keeping me
from posting anything at all so perfect
just post next and then post again next
and then post again next
um and start to look at your data and
the traction like comment commit
mentally to making 100 videos okay or
you say it's not working or you can't
make it or it's not happening for you or
whatever a hundred videos in your head
you'll get way better or like you're
probably already better now compared to
the first video I am yeah and that's
only seven videos in
okay but now imagine 70 videos in you're
gonna just be so much better and you'll
get your Rhythm and your flow down so uh
yeah before worrying about there's not
enough data or analytics to really pour
into yet when it's too soon
on a channel
uh because you know some of them have
done okay right like 84 views 170 views
on your mother's day one it's great
um
but yeah
daily commit to 100 videos you've done
seven so you got 93 more
10 minute Plus videos
and that's the start okay yeah so it
should it's okay to post seven videos
and not Market them first
um
or is it better to three and then Market
them
so have time to Market them every other
day
Market them through what like a
newsletter send yeah send them send
people the videos you post post I post
every day and then take your best video
from the past week and then put that in
your newsletter okay
so not every video will get we'll hit
your newsletter which is fine
I do 20 to 30 videos a day
wow and not every video hits a
newsletter
okay yeah
cool good luck lady what do you got well
I'm recently uh
um uh created a bunch of videos or I
recorded a bunch of videos which were
all consecutive
and I was thinking about what you said
before because normally you you start
with something like an intro and get
people to get in so somewhere in between
I made a seven minute long video which
actually got into it all but I'm still
thinking can I still use the other
tidbit because I was going for a walk
and every time I saw something I just
recorded and talked about it
thank you
so it's part of a series but you want to
also talk about other things
yeah I was I was just going forward it
was an hour
long enough I I would record a few
minutes
of things I thought about and and things
I saw and then when I actually was
sitting down that's when I made one
according to the structure you always
say
so later on I edited them all together
into one YouTube video and I was
thinking this isn't working so I I never
actually posted the video
well how do you know it's not working if
you haven't posted a video
that's true
then I'll shall just post it and maybe
change the format a little bit
yeah I mean and that's the part of if
you're committing to 100 videos
great you post it it doesn't work
awesome next
okay because you got 100 to make that's
just one you got 99 more to go you know
I will play with you
walking more and maybe you discover that
when you walk like half the audio it
sucks because the wind hit the
microphone
post next and like get a better mic next
time or don't go out on a windy day or
whatever right just post and keep going
next and in in the Rhythm you'll find
what you love
and then what actually is also
resonating with the audience and then
that's what you commit to continuing to
do but in the early stages don't say
something's not working if you haven't
posted it just because
you know the vibe was off or you know
whatever reason to post
you take your hour video and you cut it
up or you just take the hour video and
you just
hosted as is and then tomorrow and the
other one comes up and you'll find that
in those hundred videos you'll get a few
winners
awesome thank you
Andrew posted
uh how to manage work-life balance while
serving others but still avoiding
burnout so I talk about burnout super
quick in here there's not a lot on it
it's like one page on it maybe two I
think
burnout mostly happens when you don't
love what you're doing
when I if you know for example like
accounting I would burn out so fast if I
had to be an accountant I just it's just
not what I love doing
um or legal work or paperwork or
contracts and my mom's a lawyer and she
loves it right like that's her service
it's like I'm going to save people from
making tons of mistakes in their
business that's her service but for me
every time I get a contract that I look
at like oh how many pages is it okay
four okay it's not that bad
so I would get burned out super fast if
I was a lawyer
but I could do this
for a much much much longer time right
I've been going I started this morning
I'm you know two o'clock I haven't had a
break I'm gonna go all through tonight
and and it's not gonna it's not gonna
feel like work like I'm I'm doing a
stream tonight with Zan and Drew from
you know six to eight ish Zan's all
excited he's like you guys should show
up uh that I'm not looking at that like
oh really
I don't know Zan you know uh right I'm
I'm pumped I'm pumped to do it it
doesn't I don't see it as work and so I
think a lot of burnout happens because
you don't actually love the work that
you're doing
when I I was telling the story on the
podcast just before this so I broke my
neck when I was on tour right and
everybody wanted me to come home and I
tell the story and build the serve
everybody wanted me to come home and I
uh said how about we just try because
I would much rather be here with
entrepreneurs than at home when I'm
gonna do a home just lie in the bed and
feel sorry for myself like I'd much
rather be with entrepreneurs because for
me that's service that's love and love
is healing
so I'd much rather be a part of the love
energy that we get from like hey just
can you just give me four hours where I
don't have to feel my pain because I can
just be here helping entrepreneurs
uh and so
there were some limits and there were
some controls like my first speech uh my
first event was in Kansas City and we I
only went for an hour and a half instead
of the unusual three to four hours
because my wife pulled me off and said
that's um you're done like I'm she was
the boss the agreement was she would
pull me aside when I'm when I'm hitting
my limit uh because otherwise I would go
too far
um and if she wasn't in charge then she
wouldn't let me go
and I could not drive there by myself
because my neck was broken
um
so that was the only time where she ever
had to pull me off stage for the rest of
the entire tour and and I didn't feel
burnt out I felt like this was actually
part of my healing
um so there's definitely time for
self-care and there's definitely time
for going too far but I would really
look at
the tasks that are actually burning you
out it's probably because you're
spending too much time especially with
people that are just draining your
energy as opposed to lifting you up
so think about the people that you're
around you know I see John in the room
John's part of Genius Network I am too
and whenever we're in in the genius
network uh those are long events like
those are two full days once a month
you're booking off your whole Thursday
whole Friday but
but when you come back it's like oh it's
already five o'clock what happened
like so many great people so many caring
people so many people who want to serve
who want to give who want to who want to
help each other out and it doesn't feel
like you're spending a lot of time but
again if you put me in a two-day legal
conference oh my God I'm gonna be
distracted the whole time I'm going to
be doing Instagram I'm gonna be
something because I'm going to hate my
life right so a lot of times it's just
spending time with people who the people
who who suck your energy you want to
limit how much time you're spending with
them and it's not they may not be bad
people just doing work that you just
don't like doing versus
you know how good it's felt when you've
helped somebody you know when you help
somebody when you've given them wisdom
when you've told them your story and you
see the glimmer of hope in their eyes
say maybe I can do this too
you know that feels so good
and you could do that again right
afterwards and not feel drained and
you're not going to go home saying I'm
super intelligent like the nights that I
sleep the best somebody asked me how do
you what's your sleep schedule how do
you sleep the best and the usual advice
is like okay don't drink coffee after
two o'clock and have cool sheets and you
know uh have have the lights all the way
down on blackout curtains and all that
and that's all true I'm not negating any
of that but the thing for me is I say
best when I feel like I gave my best you
know like like today mattered like I
helped somebody today
that's when I I can just what a
delicious day ready to pass out what if
I feel like I didn't give enough I
played small I didn't help I wasted my
time today then I'm Restless no matter
how cool the bed is or how dark the the
light is and all that stuff right so I
think that
when you can get more into service mode
I think burnout is still real but it's
it's a lot less I think like imagine a
world like how many people are burnt out
in the world right I mean
how many how much of America is burnt
out right now Lots but imagine if
95 of America was getting burned out
because they were serving each other so
much right like that's that's a much
nicer world to live in right so I think
burnout is real but it's not usually the
cause of um
uh of serving too much it's usually
because we're doing a lot of work that
we don't like so again it is real your
balance and your self-care does
definitely matter but most of the
burners coming from things that you just
shouldn't be doing anymore
um I think for for balance you work life
balance that's uh it's a personal thing
and a shifting thing so I look at Dwayne
Johnson and he's always the example I go
to because he's kind of crazy in his
work in four hours a day like he's got
to work for work out four hours a day
right which sounds crazy to me that's
crazy right but I don't look like Dwayne
Johnson
right this is what you look like when
you don't work out four hours a day and
he's got to wake up five hours early to
go work out four hours a day to then get
to his set and to me that sounds crazy
but the him he's in the zone and that's
his like private place and meditation
like he he has to do it he's not the
same guy if he doesn't do his his
workout for four hours
um so that's his version of balance even
though we might judge it or at least I
judge it and say wow that is like not it
at all that's the opposite of balance so
it's a constant
struggle battle uh to look at your
calendar because all you got is your
time
does your the actions in your calendar
map to the Ambitions of you achieving
the life that you want
personal and business right so
um you know Saturday is my day with my
wife
and so
before covet we were doing I was always
book a new restaurant for us to go to
something new in the city for us to go
to and you couldn't reach me on a
Saturday if you follow me on Instagram I
I almost never post on a Saturday and if
I post in something it's me in in the
woods going on a hike or something but I
don't do I don't take questions I do my
10 questions with Evan every day except
Saturday
so you can ask me a question on set
because that's the time that I spent
dedicated to her
and whatever you might judge that and
say well that's stupid Evan if you're
trying to grow your business you got to
do XYZ or you might say well that's not
enough time you got to spend Friday
Saturday and Sunday like everybody's
gonna have an opinion on what you should
be doing
you're never going to please everybody
people will always judge you for what
you're doing so at the end of the day it
just comes down to what do you want
what's balance for you
you know you you how much time you want
to spend with your your husband or wife
with your kids because news flash you
don't want to spend all day with your
husband or wife either
you don't want to spend all day long
with your husband or wife doing nothing
you don't want to spend all day long in
your business you don't want to spend
all day long at the gym so like how does
that balance fit
um and I would make sure you have time
for yourself whatever that looks like
like what is personal time for you
whether that's
um
being part of something like Movie
Makers or genius Network whether that's
playing the guitar or playing some video
games or like what like your own
personal time because you need to have
your own time for your own growth so
whatever that looks like for you and
again varying amounts for some people
they need half an hour or an hour every
day and some people it's just something
on the weekend
but
I would I would look at my calendar it's
what I do I look at my calendar your
calendar is a reflection of your goals
and Ambitions right because success is
your habits it's what you're doing every
day that counts so you look at your
habits and if I do these things will
this lead to a happy life
financially spiritually emotionally
relationships like if I do these things
will it lead to a happier life and if
yes then great you do it and if not then
you change something
and most people wait to to have
something fall so far out of their life
that they make a major change
what I would love to see you do is make
more micro changes
so most people don't make a change until
they don't change their diet until they
have a heart attack you know they don't
they don't they don't quit that job and
look for a business until they just hate
their their boss so much that they have
to leave
instead of making these macro
adjustments it's better to make more
micro adjustments more frequently
so you change your schedule maybe every
week in a little tiny way if you need to
instead of sticking with the same
schedule and then five years later
totally hating your life and then having
to make some major change
um so constantly I'm looking at my
calendar and it's a reflection of what
means the most to me covet has changed a
lot of things obviously for me for
everybody
um
so look at your calendar for the next
week and say hey if I started doing
these tasks will I get closer to
achieving my goals or not
that was a good one that's a good that
was a good question hopefully a good
answer but thank you thank you Andrew uh
so as we go along guys I mean there's
still the ones in the Facebook group but
if you have questions while we're here
pop it in the chat I'll do my best to to
help answer uh Zan is saying you have to
enjoy the process BTS page 145 there you
go Dan I'm talking about there's one
about burnout there's a page on burnout
that specifically addresses that uh John
is asking seems as if you chose to work
with your natural gift and talent and
monetize it and make sure we structure
our business to fit our desired
lifestyle we last longer yeah 100
percent
100 I mean you got it John I I look at
um people who are looking forward to
retirement it's like well what what are
you retiring from right like we you want
to serve forever
and so my goal is to I want to be 120
years old and still helping
entrepreneurs in some way like I might
be in a wheelchair or I might be in a in
a home or something but as long as I can
think as long as I still got this like
everything else might fall apart but as
long as I still got my brain and I can
talk even if I can't talk I'll be
writing I'll be using my foot to paint
anything just to try to to help
um I don't I don't ever want to stop
doing it that's why the Who and the why
are constant forever and the how will
change a million different times but
um I've seen a lot of uh friends and and
parents of friends who as soon as they
stop serving as soon as they stop their
job like everything just falls apart
their health falls apart their relations
fall apart they don't have meaning
anymore and they're they're bored just
staying at home
um and so I never want to be that
um
it may not always be always on but this
service I think is it's just a human
need I think service is a human need
you always want to feel no matter how
old you are that you that today matters
to somebody that you can create
something that could change somebody's
life and that the time you spent today
was was well spent and that maybe that's
for the world or maybe that's just
spending time with your kids today and
have an impact on them or spending time
with your husband and wife today and
having an impact on them but you want to
feel like today was well spent and the
more days that you feel like you spent
the time well the happier you're going
to be and the more days you feel like
you wasted it
the more unhappy you're going to be and
I think that's why most so many people
are depressed is like they're spending
time feeling like it doesn't matter
like nobody cares if I show up today
nobody cares if I do hard work today
nobody cares
that leads to depression
uh John says not planning on turning in
my parts until God calls me home right I
love it
I love it absolutely Raymond's saying I
have two offices that I float around to
I believe changing the environment is
huge yeah and listen that's plain to
play to your strengths like what works
for you is what you have to start to do
other people might say Raymond no that's
crazy dude like don't switch between two
offices you're unfocused you're all over
the place that doesn't work because
they're working off of their operating
system
and you know that this works for you so
you do it
like the most important part of
um I was talking to somebody earlier
today about a morning routine what's
your morning routine the most important
part of a morning routine is how it
makes you feel
it's not just about checking the boxes
this is different the difference between
normal people Achievers and high
achievers most people wake up and have
no routine at all they wake up like an
accident they fall into their day they
check their phone oh my God that and
then they're just a mess
right that's most people uh Achievers
have a routine chances are you guys have
a morning routine you know what you're
going to do every morning and you check
it off the problem is
there's no feeling in most of the time
of that morning routine
you checking the Box because you know
that watching a video or reading that
book or listening to that podcast is the
thing that will get you fired up
but you're also doing it while you're
washing the dishes or brushing your
teeth or eating breakfast or something
else and so you don't get the feeling
you can check the box and say I did it I
did it but you don't feel bold you don't
feel powerful you don't actually feel
inspired that's the difference you want
to move from being an achiever to a high
achiever your morning routine has to
make you feel bold powerful inspired and
ready to take on the day
and that might mean just keeping your
morning routine but doing it with more
intention
I had a woman show up to my event in um
New Mexico and she said I asked her
what's the most powerful part of your
morning routine it's like she said
prayer so prayer was the most powerful
part of my own routine like every day
you pray every day I pray okay great how
many days do you pray and you get the
feeling of the closeness to God and
you're ready to go take on the day
and how many days do you feel like you
just kind of said the words
and she said about 50 50. like and
that's the problem right because you can
check the box to say I did it I prayed
all right next but if you're only
actually feeling it half the time the
other half the time it's it's not wasted
time but it's not actually serving you
that much
so look at your morning routine today
whatever the thing is prayer videos
workout whatever the most important
thing out of your morning routine is are
you feeling bold powerful inspired and
ready to take on the day if yes you did
a great job if no go back and do it
again or add something else in that gets
you that feeling because we've all felt
bold and powerful and confident and
inspired we just don't live there
naturally
so you have to inject that in like you
take a vitamin D supplement or a fish
oil supplement you need to have the the
belief supplement that you add to your
morning routine make it part of your
vitamins that you take every day the
belief supplement that I can do greater
things right and that's that has to be a
part of your routine and that's
different for everybody maybe you watch
The Rock working out and that gets you
jacked up or maybe you watch The Rock
working out you think that guy's crazy
um I'm not here to judge what you have
to do but it's putting that in and
having a feeling so you can move from
being achiever to a high achiever
uh uh what else finding time for
self-care and reconnect so you have more
insight to pour into other people's cups
is it is it truth for family or for any
people we serve
um everybody like you show up and you
want to spread your message everywhere
um
I read a quote from Francis Assisi last
night that I'm not I'm probably going to
butcher but the essence is
um you spread the scripture everywhere
and sometimes you use words
right it's close something like that
John's saying yes so it's not perfect
somebody can look it up and put the
exact one in but the idea is like you're
spreading your message all the time
through who you are and how you act and
sometimes you're actually using your
words
sometimes the huge fan of Saint Francis
um sometimes what people need is a video
or they need a speech or they need pep
talk sometimes people just need a hug
sometimes people just need to see you
leading by example sometimes people
seeing you hold the door for somebody
inspires them to do something sometimes
seem seeing you with your team and you
being the last on the elevator instead
of the first and letting your team go
first maybe that inspires somebody right
so it's like constantly living the
message when you go through build to
serve when you figure out you're who
right mine is believe I'm not just
believe when I turn on the camera and go
on to YouTube it I am believe it is me
right and the best it's the best me that
I'm trying to bring everywhere so if I'm
just talking to Zan privately I'm still
trying to inject him with belief it's
not a strategy it's part of who I am and
same thing for all of you you show up
to try to gift this to yourself and
everybody around you whether your
mission is big and you want to change
the world or just the you know 25
closest people to you
um
yeah you you anyway I gotta memorize
that Saint Francis one because I love
that quote but it just really struck me
because so many people think you have to
be a different person when you're going
online or when you're making content
like the best is to actually be you
right this is not just a strategy to
share for social media this is a
strategy for life so yeah your goal is
to spread your your message to everybody
because imagine like belief mine is
belief whatever yours is it's something
powerful it's something positive I've
never seen somebody's one word be
hatred or
killing or something right like it's
always positive so if yours is freedom
there it is Raymond wow I said Freedom
this is that came up like if rain wins
his freedom
imagine allowing everybody to have a
little more freedom
right he's he wants to spread freedom to
everybody he wants to spread that to his
partner his kids his grandparents his
the people in his community and the
people watching his video it's not okay
I'm going to be Freedom only for my
content and then when I come home I'm
gonna
be a terrible husband or whatever right
I mean it's Freedom everywhere
Daniel saying interesting the book I
work on right now is the same principle
it can be started at almost any page
yeah and listen I had to fight for that
my publisher didn't like it she's
they're like there's no chapters in your
book people like to read chapters so it
needs to feel more substantial
um he also didn't like how I had a quote
on every page because we're quoting
Martin Luther King or JFK or or whoever
um so don't do that only do one per like
every 100 Pages or something
um
so no I don't like that so Raymond says
I love the quotes uh yeah I guess it's
just a different style
I I wrote the book how I would like to
read the book because I don't like to
read books much I like video learning
more so because I'm a slow reader and
takes me a while I like having the
bite-sized pieces so
um I'm glad you guys liked it and it
resonated uh your one word is written
the same way my first book and it's that
same same style and I had to fight with
my publisher on that one as well it's
just not typically how books are done
right and into
um Daniel's points like I didn't I
didn't convince them that it was right
I just said this is what I want to do if
you want to work with me this is this is
this is a non-negotiable for me it has
to be an easy to read book and if that
doesn't work for you awesome
uh I'll go somewhere else right not like
in a mean way like if it doesn't fit
your style and doesn't fit your catalog
hey awesome I don't want to spend 18
months convincing you that this is the
way that publishing is going right like
this is what I want to do if we want to
work together great if not you know you
move on
um
one last Quick story on that uh Zan and
I do our our nightly gaming stream
um with I play League of Legends and we
answer business questions it's apple
carmichael.live and when I first came up
with the idea I actually offered the
opportunity to my friend Mark because we
have a podcast together and we do a lot
of work together and and I didn't want I
just felt right that he would be the
first guy that I offer it to and I said
there's no way you can do this but I
just want to let you know that I'm doing
this and I wanted to give you the first
opportunity
um he's got four kids and his wife and
his all-time and he's like hey I can
make it work if you move it half an hour
later
like I can't move it half an hour later
this is the time I have to do it so we
had to say no so then uh and I was
assuming that anyway so I then I
messaged then I got this opportunity
I want to do this with you and he and
he's uh said well okay I can do it every
day except whatever day because I got to
go pick up my wife or whatever
uh and then like no no whatever she she
can pick herself up I'm gonna do this
and I don't know whatever he worked it
out it happened you know maybe he's got
to cook extra for her or something but
you know Mark
could couldn't make it happen and Zan
did make it happen and if Zan said no
it's like hey Zen no worries man uh you
got to be with your wife great uh Pablo
I'm starting this show you interested
right I mean just I don't want to
convince Zan to change his whole life to
make this work could it be a great
opportunity for him absolutely will it
you know is it worth the effort maybe
not same thing with my friend Mark for a
decade it would have been amazing
opportunity for him to say yes but I'm
not I don't want to be in the business
of convincing people right it's just so
much easier to go faster when you're not
trying to convince people
Pablo's question was serving money how
to set priorities your mindset for
Revenue so
this is a big reason why I wrote built
to serve because a lot of people have a
hard time making money off of their
purpose and you have a hard time asking
and a hard time monetizing as a result
you end up doing the thing
in the evenings and weekends and then
having to have some other job that you
don't like just to pay the bills I know
Zan and I have talked a bunch about
making money on our on our live streams
because Zane has a hard time asking for
money it's like no Zane you got it you
gotta charge this is how much it is we
got to charge you gotta right it doesn't
mean that you still can't give things
away for free
um at every event that I go to when I'm
speaking
there's always uh usually five to ten
percent of people that will give tickets
away for free
um
some people are homeless and you never
know it
you know you'd never know it by looking
at them that they're homeless
um
so you can still have that as an as an
element as a part of it but you have to
make money because if you're not making
money then you don't
you don't
build your business you don't build your
purpose you don't impact more people
like look at the reach that I'm able to
have
because of the team if this was me Evan
Carmichael part-time doing things I
probably wouldn't even have written this
book
we wouldn't be here talking
and so as I say in the book you know
money has to be in your top five just
not number one
so you have to learn how to make money
off your business you have to because
because otherwise you're stuck with a
job that you hate uh
it just can't be number one it can't be
above everything else so when people
come in we had a guy in our live stream
two days ago I think came in and said
hey I've got a I've got two business
ideas the first one I enjoy and I
struggle with this and I want to help
other people through it and then the
other one this is hot opportunity with
my cousin like no the first one
like don't do like hot opportunity with
your cousin that's just not the one but
that's that's how most people start a
business that's that's what most people
they just think they're gonna make a
quick Buck
um as opposed to actually being deeply
connected to it and that's when you end
up losing so it's got to be money's got
to be in your top five just not number
one
does that help probably go deeper since
since you're here that was your topic
does that help you with where you're at
yeah so some sometimes it's kind of a
you know until what is what do you do
what do you do free what you how do you
charge how much do they charge you know
sometimes uh
um I don't know I I help a lot of people
and and I feel that pressure you know
like today finally uh I get all every
day you know I you know I have this
problem you know this help me with this
I'm being helping for it for years you
know but also it just even you have two
people that that many times they they
help me they bring the the issues and
and today was the first time they say if
you wanna
you wanna uh me to answer you just do it
through the YouTube you know so so at
least at least I I don't I used to I
used to do for WhatsApp you know I used
to do it on on the email yeah and now I
say no YouTube and if you don't do it in
YouTube but you know it's just I I feel
like it's hard because the kind of
problem you know one person one woman
was abused and you know she need to
negotiate she need to do another person
solve their business and this and so
people that that financially they're not
stable so I don't know but uh yeah so so
let's get super tactical here one in
your bio of all your social accounts we
need to have something that talks about
what they can buy
so it could be hire me for coaching it
could be check out my new book it could
be like whatever you whatever you have
for sale this is what I told Zane to do
because Zane will just give everything
away spend all his time for free and and
just love on everybody it's like Zan you
need to make money you got to do this so
when he started doing uh his bill to
serve Readers Club that um that we
launched
as he gets better at going through the
book and coaching
the idea is to train him to be a built
to serve coach and help people who go
deeper because I'm not I'm not coaching
I'm not doing coaching consultant
services I don't I don't want to do it
but Zane does so that's got to be in
your bio you got to let people know that
it's available and in the Facebook post
we talk about here's this free group
that we're launching that you can be a
part of and if you want to go deeper
with me here's I also do coaching and
here's the link
so you have you have it as part of your
default messaging so think about your
social media accounts think about your
email wherever you could potentially
talk about yourself I want you to put in
I need people to know that you have
something to sell like this is this is
the advice of people who struggle some
people are just over selling selling
everything as a sales pitch right that's
that's what you probably want to avoid
becoming and you're afraid that you
might be judged like that so
uh step number one in your social bio I
need to know like whatever what's the
what are you selling Pablo are you
selling coaching you're selling a
training what are you selling yeah
selling yeah coaching programs that have
different different time of year like in
March with the next problem yeah so so
something in your bio that says DM me
for coaching
you see right DM me for leadership coach
you know DME for whatever specific
coaching
um yeah just so that it's because you're
not gonna you're not gonna offer it by
default so I want to see it in the bio
so people know that you're doing it
um the next thing is if it's
uh free then make them go through some
hoops
you're spending your time on it make
make them have to do something so
telling them to ask you on YouTube is a
is is a hoop
um some people on mine
uh will be hey join us live on Instagram
join us live on sorry join us live on
YouTube
for the live stream that I do with with
Zan and Drew so somebody asked me a
question on Instagram uh and it's going
to be a long one I just respond to say
hey let's get into it on on my YouTube
live we're going live tonight at six
o'clock join us
and if they're not willing to do that
like they have to they have to show up
right they've got to own their step a
little bit
um we've had a guy who comes who's come
like eight times or something to our
live stream named Mike who keeps asking
the same questions over and over and
over again it's like Mike like he's
always asking purpose really the
questions so Mike did you get built to
serve yet like you have to get we're
going to help you Zan's gonna do a free
one-on-one session with you Zan offered
but you have to you have to get a copy
built to serve
buy it on Amazon get the free version
like sign up for an audio audible trial
and get the free audio book anything
like you have to all your questions are
on purpose the answers are in built to
serve you have to go pick it up
and you know Zane doesn't even get
anything from it right if if we got a
sale from Amazon woohoo right anything
Zayn's not making anything but but we're
making him jump through
a hoop like you have to you have to show
if you're gonna show up for them they
have to at least do something to meet
you not even halfway but like take a
step show me that you're committed
show me that you're willing to do
something
yeah right so I like that of pushing
them to YouTube or pushing them
somewhere else so it shows you who's
willing to step up and be a little bit
more committed and I'm
I'm happy to if people want to show up
I'm happy to do it most people don't
show up and that's a problem so we had a
guy who wanted to interview me for his
podcast and I get
there's tons of interview requests for
podcasts so I said come and join us on
the uh the Youtube live and let's talk
about it so he came into YouTube live
and and I said
um I appreciate you showing up I'm super
busy right now but talk to me in the new
year and this was in maybe October or
something
uh maybe Zan remembers is October
November uh and then he came back in
January and he said hey I'm just
reminding you hey we said January I said
you know what yeah let's do it and and I
was I don't know if I was his first
guest or his like fourth guest he's like
right at the beginning brand new
um and because he was willing to jump
through the Hoops he got
he got access right and so that's
something that at the beginning
if you only get four comments a day it's
easy to respond to everybody but as you
grow that's going to be a real Demand on
your time and so one letting people know
that you have a paid version and then
two for free yes we still do some but
you have to jump through a few Hoops to
make it happen
um and then the third thing I'd offer
out is
uh having it public
so I'll help you on my Instagram live
come on on my Instagram live and we'll
work I'll we'll work through it
um and if they're not willing to you
know option one they're not willing to
pay you option two they're not willing
to
go to another platform and and ask you a
question on YouTube or three they're not
willing to go live with you on Instagram
it's like you gotta you gotta you gotta
show up somewhere like I'm trying here
right you gotta you gotta pull like take
that at least one step in to show me
that you're a little bit committed so
that it's it's a use of your time right
a good use of your time
um so those those three things and that
that will weed out a lot of people but
also bring you the people who are
actually ready for Change and for action
so that you don't feel like you're
wasting your time
yeah yeah welcome Louise welcome aboard
uh what else what do you guys got this
is a it's a it's a small group today so
we can make it intimate yeah I did it I
did it I'm doing the coaching the the
coaching one-on-one you know for for the
free for the free version you know and
that is that is very good you know just
I I feel on my on my group but many many
other people that comment
so but definitely definitely I need to
put a very very clear many people know
you know but uh but they just uh because
I I've been trying to build like
Community build a community on Tuesdays
where we meet you know there is like a
150 200 people you mean for Zoom you
know and and and I I teach them I work I
work on this and after that I stay one
hour with everyone you know but um but
uh some sometimes I just
they just get in no no tired but
um there is a lot of stalkers you know
there's a there's a lady that uh they
would they would appear for everywhere
and you know and and appeared on on my
WhatsApp appearing on this for
everywhere and and she will she will
follow me and my team you know this a
lot you know a lot of weird people you
know
so so so so you know and I'm more
exposed you know like so so I said oh my
God you know like now we need to deal
with it with that and and my my bigger
fear I don't know how you you feel but
my biggest fear is I say no stop it you
know stop it that's enough you know is
if she's going to go and put this
comment bad comment on on on the
Facebook there was another there was a
guy in another country that also was
talking to me last year you know I said
stay man stop it just stop it you know
I'm not going to answer I'm not going to
do that you know that's that's your
issue you know that's this you know and
and he want to make a a nasty comment
you know and so so that's that's my fear
that
I don't know it makes sense or no no
most of the time honestly it's just
ignoring
like most of them are just attention
Seekers
it doesn't happen that often but when it
does the the telling somebody to stop it
usually doesn't work usually just gets
them even more upset it's just ignoring
until they it's like the the little kid
who's yelling and raging and freaking
out and if you just ignore them they
they calm down or go you know go the
bully go pick on somebody else but if
you
um
yeah I just found like trying to or or
you have to go deep and Coach them like
or you have to like just telling
somebody to stop it is gonna be
you're likely to get him in defensive
mode yeah so you have to either coach be
willing to coach them through it or just
ignore them yeah because otherwise
you're making it worse
yeah yeah I did
but that that's that's like any coaching
if you're gonna dive into somebody's
problem
yeah um
at the beginning you make it worse
and they get defensive like a great
coach if you're not bumping up against
defensiveness you're not doing your job
as a coach you're right you have to be
when you when they start being defensive
that means you actually hit on something
if you're just saying yes yes yes yes
yes they're probably not going to follow
through and do anything
it's when they get defensive like ooh
okay that's let's talk about this
because this is your block right here
but to dive into that you have to be
able to pull them out on the other side
you can't just leave them hanging
in in the negativity
so if you don't either one want to put
in the effort to do it or two don't
think you can then it's better not to
address it at all because you're just
going to make it worse
yeah especially when they don't pay you
sure but
if you're doing even in the free
sessions I'd say
um
like you do an Instagram live coaching
yeah yeah okay you said you know you you
become yourself extra homework Pablo now
I want you in your Instagram live
sessions to say so normally I do this as
a paid service I'm a I get paid to coach
people on how to
like what do you what what's the
coaching you do leadership
uh negotiation you know how to approach
deals yeah yeah so so normally I do this
kind of work
I get paid to train people and how to
negotiate I work with sales people and
CEOs and entrepreneurs to help them
close more effective deals and that's
that's my business I get paid to do this
but
every week on Tuesday I like going live
as a free service for everybody to be
able to learn from and today
we've got whoever
on and I'm going to help him right so
that people know you're still doing the
free thing but that people know that you
do this as a service as well it's not a
hard pitch it's not saying and remember
go hire me
right but you're sending contacts as
you're the expert you get paid for this
in the beginning in the beginning of the
session
yeah in the beginning of the session and
you can storytell in the middle if it
makes sense
right so you know for example one of my
clients when I was just working with a
client on this yesterday
and his biggest problem was he didn't
know how to X right the fact that you're
saying one of my clients obviously not
going to say the name and what company
they're from and you can change the I'll
change gender a lot I'll say guy when
it's a girl and the opposite because it
doesn't matter who the person is it's
just the story right
um so that people know if you're telling
stories about how you're coaching people
it's not it's not what the just intent
to try to sell people you're you're
telling that story for a reason
but it positions you as a coach and that
oh he does this as a service oh maybe
maybe he can help me negotiate my next
deal
mm-hmm yeah
perfect yeah
I have a question yeah
go ahead so
um I saw you and Cam's uh IG live and
you suggested that he you know do a
30-day challenge well I had already had
this workbook that I had created like
last October November so I decided to
launch it and I did I got two people
that signed up
but I closed the registration on the
25th because I wanted to just like you
know focus and make sure I was walking
them through the workbook and I got the
Facebook group and all that other stuff
but it it prompted me because I've been
really wanting to do like a six-month
program where I walk people through how
I you know changed my mindset and got to
the space that I'm in today
um and I'm really not sure how I want to
do it I don't know if I want to do it
just in 30 day increments you know like
the first month we do mental the second
month we do emotional the third month we
do spiritual or if I just want to offer
it as like a six month program
um I still want to keep the same format
where people come into the Facebook
group and it's a private Facebook group
and I'm there you know offering support
I'm there going over the the questions
every week I'm just needing more
I guess more Direction on how to
effectively Market that or your your
Genius expertise on how I should really
launch that
I just drank down the wrong way
perfect timing um I think six months is
too long
okay
um I think somebody might sign up for it
but I think what I would do is
have your different modules break it up
into six different things
okay and then I need to be able to join
in the next module
so as long as they're not building on
each other right like
module one if it's mindset what's module
one module one is mental mental mental
so what I'm doing is six pillars of
um got it what's what's the name of
number two
number two is emotional perfect so I I
need to be able to join at emotional
okay I missed
the mindset or the mental okay they're
they're connected it's part of this
whole thing but right but they don't
have to go they don't have to flow like
that they don't have to flow I don't
feel like if I join in on the second one
I missed out on the first one
the self-contained modules with
challenges if you want like here's what
we're going to do in the next 30 days
somebody might sign up for all
all six months of them all six pillars
at once right awesome but you can have
that as an option most people won't most
people will just sign up for hey we're
starting our
30-day emotional challenge
to help you get your emotions right for
your business or however you want to
position it and
and they could still sign up for the
whole year or for the whole six months
right they just get mental at the end
gotcha right so I should just keep it
rolling
every every so after the six months is
up we start the next seventh month on
mental yep okay and you've learned
something now because you've now gone
through it with people your mental at
seven will be better than mental at one
right and then what I would do is give
some kind of alumni discount say hey you
want to go through this whole thing
again
okay you get it again at like a quarter
of the price or something okay so yeah I
was thinking about doing the six
um different modules and then just group
you know I still want to keep it like at
the same price point you know it's just
the workbook but you get the free
Facebook group Community me there you
know doing lives at the end of the week
and every single day or every week
coming on to go over the challenges or
whatever I have for that week but
um
and then offer so what I just create one
book for the people who want the six
months all together or do I still keep
them separately separate okay and you
give them all six books okay or six PDFs
or whatever yep six PDF Zan and I were
talking about this too with the built to
serve readers group it's like it's got
to be long enough that people can learn
and interact and have fun and and you
know make connections but if the group
starts up every six months it's just it
just takes way too long to get the next
cohort going right so built to serve
does does build like it's hard to jump
in at chapter eight and Zayn's talking
about who I how and they're like what
does that mean you know so the book goes
into sequence but but for you yeah if
you're looking at a six-month program
that's your best bet you sell the 30
days you sell the six months and then
you sell once they've gone through it to
come back and do it all over again just
as as a refresher at a
discounted rate
so just one more thing so
um really what I was thinking about
doing is like April to October then
taking November off and then starting
back in December would no you just want
me to just go right into November okay
because it's just gonna be some people
sign up on month four but but for them
like I wouldn't even label it because
it's not month four right it's not the
fourth pillar this is this each pillar
is its own thing okay and we go through
six in in six months and then you can
join as an alumni and come back at a
discounted price okay it's got to feel
like a new thing every time okay and
that I didn't miss out on anything okay
I know we gotta go but real quick
Belinda what do you got
um I know you don't like Facebook ads
but like for my products especially my
books I mean I don't know how else to
get it out there without doing an ad
what would you suggest
did I say it on like Facebook guides I
don't mind I don't Facebook ads are
great Facebook itself sucks but but
advertisement Facebook and Instagram ads
can be great
um I think the thing with Facebook with
any advertisement is you have to figure
out the messaging first
so you you have to be talking to people
to know what they connect with so as an
example with with TDS right now my salsa
dancing company uh we're launching
virtual classes because people can't
come in and do
you know in-person salsa classes right
now so Alex is off dming people on
Instagram telling them about a free
class that we have and playing with what
what headline like what what's he typing
into the message and then trying to get
them on a call to talk about it to see
what did they resonate with so when he's
giving his pitch or talking about what
we do what questions do they ask and
what resonates with them like what's the
thing that gets people to then go take
the free class from the conversation
that's a giant waste of time like I I
don't need Alex talking for 30 minutes
to get one person into a free class but
what it what it does that doesn't scale
hard but it gives you the market
feedback to know okay when I use this
phrase when I say this sentence when I
position it like this that's what gets
people to open my message and then go to
the free class
that's what then you turn into an
advertisement
okay at the beginning you don't know
what's going to work and so it's it's a
it's a it's a waste of money or or it's
like a learning experience you either
learn by spending a whole bunch of money
on a bunch of different ideas or you
learn by doing the work and talking to
people
so he just DMS random people not people
that's following him just random people
he's dming people so part of the class
is is
is um personal development so it's like
people who join salsa it's not just to
learn the salsa steps they want to make
an improvement in their life right
they're more they don't like where
they're at right now they want to learn
a new skills on their bucket list
something right so he's looking up
hashtag personal development
and then damning people who are in
Canada the US
and that's it but that's like hitting 50
people a day 100 people a day he does a
text message and then a video like hey
Belinda
and then whatever he can what you know
every day is a slightly different
message
right and just to see what people
connect with that then want to set up a
call with him to then talk about the
free class
again it doesn't scale very hard it's a
lot of time but zero money it's just
your time to do it but as he's getting
feedback for what
what people are connecting with
that goes on your landing page so when
you're talking about the book what's the
headline at the top when you're creating
the ad what's the copy what's the
picture when you know what people are
talking about what what they connect
with it's a lot easier for you to make a
better ad
um so for example when we first came up
with the landing page we use text like
you deserve an adventure
let let us teach you let's let's have a
great adventure tonight with salsa
dancing and
Adventure wasn't connecting when he said
Adventure on the phone nobody resonated
with it so our headline is wrong we need
to take off Adventure like don't talk
about Adventure anymore so as you're
talking to people you say you deserve an
adventure and you see them do nothing
like I didn't I didn't that wasn't a
good okay uh well and then you're kind
of fumbling to come up with whatever
else you can think of and then you say
something like oh that okay great and
then you update the landing page to have
that right so right now it's much more
about
um people feel like they're not
connected they're not connected to
people and that's the messages coming up
so we'll update the page to talk about
connection
and when Alex was talking to more people
it's talking about connection and when
we really dialed that in then it's going
to go to ads Facebook ads Instagram ads
YouTube ads that talk about having
connection right now
because we know that that message works
right
um
if you said hey I've got 10K just to
throw away and test great it's faster
through Facebook ads
but you're going to lose a lot of money
versus just talking to potential
customers and seeing what what resonates
with them if you want to get a copy of
build to serve and join us live for our
next training with me to ask your
questions you can go get the book right
there next to me right there I'll see
you there I'll see you to get the book
it's a good one much love